I remember hearing stories about Witchers.
Is it true what they say?
Elves were the original sorcerers
of the continent.
When humans and monsters arrived,
elves taught the humans
how to turn chaos into magic.
And then... the humans slaughtered them.
Chaos is the most dangerous thing
in this world.
But without control,
chaos will kill you.
So, that's all life is to you?
Monsters and money?
It's all it needs to be.
Something out there waits for you.
This child will be extraordinary.
Yennefer, imagine the most powerful woman
in the world.
Do you have what it takes?
Nilfgaard are here.
She's why they came.
You can't outrun destiny
just because you're terrified of it.
It's coming.
Find Geralt of Rivia.
I can't do this without you.
No matter what you choose,
you'll come out bloody.